well let's tell people how you got the
nickname poopy oh yeah yeah it's a great
we're not going to water it down no we
won't so yeah
so [ __ ] jackass was thriving we were
thriving on it it was the mtv series
every friday night at 10 p.m 20 years
ago yeah 20 years ago how are you now 35
okay so we're talking 21 years ago yeah
so i was four yeah 14 15 and
dude we loved it we're [ __ ] we're
inspired inspired so inspired and we are
all surfers and we like to do dumb [ __ ]
and at this point you're living in
carlsbad california yeah at this point
i've been living in carlsbad california
san diego county yup san diego county
north county
i had a house on acacia street on
garfield and acacia and i live next to
the beach and
[ __ ] i would just like
pretty much
at that time after i dropped out i got a
construction job because i was at the
surf shop you said this was before you
dropped out this was right after i
dropped out so i was like [ __ ] school my
name's poopies no one likes me no no no
no we're talking about before you tell
them
yeah okay okay he's trying he's trying
to sidestep this one this is great
okay let's get it back to it
and you wanted to impress your dumb
buddies yeah you were inspired by
jackass you pulled down your parents and
took a dump
in an intersection in the middle of the
road yeah so the next day we all woke up
i think we stay i stay tonight at my
friend's house that morning we woke up
there's no waves we're [ __ ] bored and
my friend's like dude let's do something
stupid i was like i gotta take a [ __ ]
right now he's like dude poo my name was
sean sean go take a [ __ ] in the middle
of the intersection and we'll [ __ ]
watch you and hopefully did they video
it dude we have the video but i can't
find it someone was videoing
someone someone was videoing but i think
they got too scared when the cops showed
up because the neighbors called the cops
um they called my dad
how long are you [ __ ] for
dude not that long at all so you were
done
it was the hype up i was so nervous to
get into the street so we're all hanging
out on the corner of the sidewalk you
know and i i found a gorilla mask and
gorilla gloves ah you took a [ __ ] as a
gorilla yeah so i went to my friend's
closet i was like [ __ ] what can i find
to hide my face you know
so i found a gorilla mask gorilla gloves
and we're all walking out to the streets
like it's pretty much like 20 feet from
my friend's house so we're all in the
corner i'm like [ __ ] should i do this or
not should i do this or not did you get
a big log dude you know what's funny is
i was pooping
and i had to pinch it off because i seen
the cops coming ah wow they came that
quick they came because the neighbors
were like he had to go get the [ __ ]
mask and check okay so like so i see the
cops coming i pinch it off and i pull up
my pants and then all my friends did
this they just bail they're out because
they're not your friends they they
they're they are i don't know they're
not on meth now
no no they all have families and they're
doing well but okay but yeah the cops
pull up cops pull up i'm like tripping
out i try to ditch my gorilla mask and
gloves and act like nothing's going on
like excuse me sir get over here please
did they put handcuffs on you yeah they
handcuffed me and then the neighbor came
out and told them what was happening and
they go
well we're gonna call your dad because
you're too young to you know right to
freaking put you in jail so they call my
dad and my dad comes down he's all
pissed off
he goes what the [ __ ] going on yeah
papa poo dude he came in hot what the
[ __ ] going on well your son was over
here taking a [ __ ] in the street
and um yeah the neighbors called the
cops and uh now we have him here and he
just and he takes me by my he grabs me
by my shirt he's like
he tells the cops he's like i'll deal
with him when we get home i was like
he's like dragging me dude and then
[ __ ] we get in the truck his truck he
goes
poopies that was the funniest it was at
sean at the time he goes sean that was
the funniest [ __ ] i've ever [ __ ]
heard of and he i was like i'm not in
trouble he goes no you're not in trouble
i was like [ __ ] yeah so that's when dad
started supporting my [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ] yeah when uh did you
find out that you were actually in legal
trouble for that um when um
they gave me a ticket
when do you make the conscious decision
like you wake up and you're like
i'm not going to school anymore for the
rest of my life you were 15 yeah i was
15 to sophomore year half a sophomore
year because my name became poopies and
i hated school because i'd show up to
school
what's your poopies like they just rub
it in so it was before
whether we've had that you got the name
poopies before you dropped out and then
we got it it was happening
after he got the name he keeps going to
school and they're calling you poop yeah
[ __ ] in the street went back to school
was the kid who [ __ ] in the street and
that's why they called you
yes and every chick did not want to even
talk to me i never went to one prom one
um homecoming
not even one of those so you didn't like
the name at first but i hated the name
dude and my friends were dicks at the
time and they you know when you don't
like your name
or you don't like somebody yeah it's
jokes you know you're for sure it sticks
when you're like [ __ ] you guys stop
calling me that oh
[ __ ] i shouldn't have even said that
because
you should have said you loved it right
away and then they would have never
called you that my friends were such
dicks dude i'd be skateboarding around
doing like little surf turns you know
and every turn i do they go
i get so [ __ ] pissed dude i'm just
trying to skate around you know and then
every trying to go they
go and dude it pissed me the [ __ ] off so
i stopped going to school and i'd go to
the surf shop so my dad would drop me
off at school
and i'd have my beach cruiser and i'd
wait for him to leave and i'd [ __ ]
turn my bike straight down to the beach
so your dad didn't know you were
dropping out didn't know when did he
find out like a month later and then he
was like oh because i gave the school
the wrong number
to call you know can you call your
parents boy so i gave him the wrong
number you're not that dumb after all
yeah i was like [ __ ] you i'm getting
away with this you know i'm like not
going to school going to the surf shop
surfing all day so when did you embrace
the name poopies dude so when i went to
hawaii you're still conflicted about it
i know yeah dude
did you did you did does your tinder say
poopies now
no it says shawn because i'm still weird
about the when like i meet chicks dude i
don't go high on poopies i go hi i'm
sean and then my friends goes what
that's not your name his name's poopies
i'm like dude shut the [ __ ] up yeah
you're like dude i'm trying to crush
some beevo yeah dude i need some puss
you guys are getting laid i didn't lose
my virginity until i was 19 because my
name was poopies
no [ __ ] jokes
oh he took a [ __ ] in the street
yeah but they don't get the jackass
thing that you know they're like
we were just that savage we loved it and
no one else liked it you know because
they're all jocks and [ __ ] we're there
surfers and skaters we loved it but the
jocks and all the hot chicks that you
want to hook up with they don't like
that [ __ ] so yeah it was definitely like
a
definitely a [ __ ] block for me i mean
it's a great name
i love it now like i [ __ ] love my
name now like except when you're trying
to crush beef
well now they go wait you're poopies
and now it's like whole 360. i'm like
yeah baby
yeah i'm poopies that's what's up yeah
but now it's a whole 360 which is i
gotta still stay humble you know you
can't take that power too far but
you know when they call me poopies i'm
like yeah you know and then they go but
there's it's funny i've known people for
like two years and they go so what's
your real name like they won't even know
my real name for like two times sean
mcinerney yep is he right yeah wow yeah
good job attention it's like two names
mack and ernie yeah
sean
when
patrick
got your hotel tonight i was like sean i
was like [ __ ] i just put mgm gm gm
i gotta go explain that when we go to
the hotel tonight yeah for sure so
serious when you
got to hawaii that you met
jamie o'brien yeah not not uh two years
after actually my first winner i didn't
meet him then my second winner i met him
okay and i didn't meet him
um i was actually hanging out with his
filmer damien robertson
and we're kicking it you know um he's
kind of like hey i'll film a couple
clips for you if you get a good one i
was like sick cool and then i found out
he was jamie's filmer i'm like what
you're [ __ ] jamie o'brien's filmer
yeah you want to come over and hang out
we're going to barbecue tonight and so i
came over
and um they go yeah this is damien goes
yeah this is my friend poopy's and jamie
goes what your name's poopies were you
bummed that he introduced you as poopies
kind of because i was trying so when i
went to hawaii i was trying to get rid
of my nickname i went to i was like yes
there's no more poopies and my friend
thiago he's like bro his name's poopies
you guys
don't let him tell you his name's not
poopies i was like [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ] i try to get rid of that
name i tried to escape the name and it
followed me dude to hawaii yeah so
they're like [ __ ] why they call you
poopy's a tom story you know but it was
funny because james he told the whole
story
[Applause]
but no jamie it was funny because jamie
kind of felt bad for me he's like dude
i'm not going to call you poopies i'm
going to call you sean a week later he's
like your name's [ __ ] poopy dude you
sweep the floors [ __ ] do the dishes
and we'll [ __ ] go surf a little bit
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]